okay so there's this there's the spirit
of good let's say and what the spirit of
good does is act in the world on the
potential of the world to generate the
actuality of the world and the
judeo-christian proposition is is that
if you confront the potential of the
world with good in mind using truth
truthful communication then the order
that you extract is good and then that's
echoed in Genesis when God is using the
word and he creates cosmos out of
potential and every time he does that he
says and it was good which is I think
it's so interesting because there's a
proposition there in the proposition
there is that if you encounter potential
with truth the cosmos you create is
actually good well that's that's just an
absolutely overwhelming idea it's like
if it's true if it's true it's the
greatest idea there ever was yeah